Vint Cerf has warned that we may lose all
our important data if we rely on digital storage,
but who is this guy and what does he know
anyway?
Oh he helped invent the internet?
Ohhh…
Hello out there in meat space, magnetic ones
and zeros decoded as the image of Julian here
for DNews.
Doomsday prophets run rampant on the internet
and usually they’re pretty easy to tune
out, but when the vice president of Google
warns of a digital dark age, it’s kind of
hard not to take notice.
Vint Cerf, along with being vp of google and
therefore having dibs on any gmail address
he wants, helped develop the internet in 1969.
He and Bob Khan created the Transmission Control
Protocol and Internet Protocol for ARPANET,
which allowed computers to send data to each
other and is the basis for the internet.
I bet he tells “Cerf the internet jokes”
all the time at parties.
Side note, the World Wide Web was developed
20 years later by a British scientist at CERN.
Tim Berners-Lee’s Hypertext Transfer Protocol
or Http makes accessing web sites possible,
but the world wide web is built upon the internet
and the two terms are not synonymous.
At this point though nobody seems to care
unless they’re arguing over who invented
it.
Ok history lesson aside, Cerf believes that
storing things digitally isn’t bulletproof
as you might think.
And the elder of the internet may have a point.
Digital mediums do degrade over time, sure,
but even if the information is good there’s
the problem of accessing it.
What’s a universal device today might be
totally obsolete in a decade.
It’s why you don’t see floppy diskettes
or laser disks anymore.
What’s a laser disk you ask?
Exactly.
But even if we keep the hardware around we
still need the software to decode it.
Digital data are just ones and zeros but there
are many different formats they can be arranged
in.
New and better formats are developed all the
time, and there’s no guarantee of backwards
compatibility.
Without software that can interpret the information,
it’s all gobbledigook.
That’s why you need to stay strong and keep
saying not today to that Java update.
But you can’t hold out forever, and you’d
need to keep transferring your data to new
mediums and formats, which sounds like a lot
of effort.
Plus you may miss something you don’t realize
is important until it’s too late.
Like the very first web page ever?
It’s gone.
CERN is trying to rebuild it.
I guess they didn’t think this whole website
thing would take off.
So Cerf recommends printing and storing documents
and pictures physically.
But there’s a reason we don’t do this
already: where would you put all of it???
Paper, thin as it is, takes up huge amounts
of space because it’s a relatively inefficient
way to store data.
I think however I may have found a solution.
DNA.
For years scientists have had the idea that
if DNA can save genetic information, why can’t
it be used to store digital information too?
George Church, a Harvard professor who is
mapping the human genome, thought he’d try
that as a fun little side project.
In 2012 he appeared on the Colbert Report
with a copy of his book, and then produced
a vial with a slip of paper on it. and on
the paper was a tiny dot.
And on that dot was DNA with its base pairs
of AT and GC representing 1’s and 0’s.
That single dot of DNA contained 20 million
copies of his book.
So why aren’t we rocking smartphones with
20 gazillion terabytes of storage on DNA drives?
Well for a number of reasons, the technology
isn’t ready yet.
First off, DNA has issues of longevity.
It reacts with its environment and errors
in the data are caused by heat or radiation.
Dr. Robert Grass of Zurich's Department of
Chemistry and Applied Biosciences may have
solved the problem by encasing the DNA in
silica spheres 150 nanometers in diameter.
They tested it by keeping the glass coated
DNA heated between 60 and 70 degrees celsius
for a month to simulate the passage of hundreds
of years, and when they separated the DNA
from the silica with a fluoride solution they
found it was just fine, thanks.
It’s also not cheap, with a megabyte costing
over $12,000, and it’s not easy to access
quickly.
But this way you can keep every single TV
show and Movie ever made in a solo cup for
thousands of years.
So long as we keep a method to decode it,
there’s no reason we should lose a thing.
Maybe that’ll help Cerf rest a little easier.
Long term storage is one of the few advantages
paper has over digital.
Trace explains why over here.
Are you worried about your digital storage?
What’s your strategy to keep everything
safe.
I have a bunch of back up hard drives at home
with all these episodes on it because I want
to make sure I’m immortal.
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.